Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that
are gone. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone. Kappa Pogchamp,
Kappa Forehead, BibleThump, Twitch emotes. I remember typing Dan's game, ForeheadSwiftRage,
PJSaltandFailfish. Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's
feeling fine. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone. Kappa Pogchamp,
Kappa Forehead, BibleThump, Twitch emotes. Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he
calls me. His doggy emote reminds me of a time far away. Looking at a chat, I get a feeling
that I'll miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel
you're not alone. Pogchamp, Kappa Forehead, BibleThump, Twitch emotes.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone. Kappa Pogchamp, Kappa Forehead,
BibleThump, Twitch emotes. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone. Twitch emotes from long ago made
you feel you're not alone. Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone. Twitch emotes from
long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes from long ago
made you feel you're not alone.
Twitch emotes
Twitch emotes from long ago